[Applaudissements]
vous dire que agatha roulant qui est sur
le dossier de coulon semaine à la bossé
dur dur plage il ya des perdants alors
qu' on a comme et ils ne voient pas
julien je n'ai qu'un tableau alors à
votre avis qui était contrôleur de train
olalala maxi maxime maxime nom d'un non
lieu après alors y avait un couteau dans
le train il y avait une vendeuse de
bracelets sur la plage y avait un forain
ou une foraine sur un manège un
ramasseur de pommes de terre maintenant
des bananes on aurait trouvé qu'ils
étaient il y avait ainsi chuté à guichet
dans une banque
une hôtesse en boîte de nuit ah ah ça
c'est une ouvreuse au cinéma un
journaliste et un pizzaïolo y avait un
journaliste j'aurais les séries a bondi
sur elle et melvin et la commission
médias
[Rires]
gypsy qu'au premier train maxi maxi
matin vers la route avait initié la
bombe a baissé pour premier boulot c'est
gentil alors de train c'était pour payer
les études et mon père était contrôleur
sncf sur quelles lignes tu faisais bas
tout paris bordeaux hendaye
sacha pas en fait ça ça ça change la
question sur quelle ligne ça nous avance
beaucoup de gens se vend 2 de brasser
sur la planche et une franche et sincère
pour aller vendre tout n'importe quoi
pour quoi à n'importe quel prix saïd ali
beiba c'était trop bien sûr bah oui
domine donc j'avais 16 ans fabriquer des
passagers on est sur la bonne voie et
foraine rouler
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'avais un très bon niveau j'ai dû
arrêter matin au niveau en raison
d'allergies du cateau médicaux perruchot
lesggy à l'orgue et sur l'a10 à hôtesses
imboden eu beau temps il ya de fortes
chances d aller à billets pour les
bosseurs et on a sauté dans l'addition
d'une banque c'est vrai c'était mon
premier job étudiant 18 ans cela vous
allez juste 18 ans le jeu j'ai fêté mon
anniversaire 15 jours le 16 juin je
travaille est incroyable c'est quelqu'un
qui est âgé parce que oui et vallourec 4
je vais vous avez payé ma chaussure dans
le journalisme
oui c'était à michel portal et vélo
c'est bon pied à vélo c'était bois ça
s'appelait s'attabler fringale c'est sa
a déposé le bilan très vite